A quick note. The following story acknowledges the existence of Santa Claus and explores his origin story. If you or someone in the car seat next to you are not ready to hear that, you might want to save this episode for another time. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Slovenia is a small country in central Europe, nestled between Italy, Austria, Croatia and Hungary.
简短说明。接下来的故事承认圣诞老人的存在，并探索他的起源故事。如果你或坐在你旁边车座上的人还没准备好听到这些，你可能想把这一集留到以后再听。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。斯洛文尼亚是中欧的一个小国，坐落在意大利、奥地利、克罗地亚和匈牙利之间。
It's a land of snowy white peaks, green valleys, intercoise rivers, beautiful and all seasons, although especially at Christmas time. It snowed really early on during my first winter here and it was just magical. It felt like I was walking through a Christmas card. That's reporter Will Aspenar. I moved here from the UK with my wife and young family back in 2018 because we were enchanted with Slovenia's landscape and wanted a new life for the kids. And in that first year we were really curious what Christmas was going to be like in this snow globe of a country. We love Christmas,
这是一片白雪皑皑的山峰、绿色山谷、蜿蜒河流的土地，四季皆美，尤其是在圣诞节期间。我在这里的第一个冬天，雪下得特别早，简直太神奇了。感觉就像走在一张圣诞贺卡里。那是记者威尔·阿斯佩纳。我于2018年带着妻子和年幼的孩子从英国搬到这里，因为我们被斯洛文尼亚的风景所吸引，想为孩子们开启新的生活。在那第一年，我们真的很好奇，在这个像雪景球一样的国家，圣诞节会是什么样子。我们热爱圣诞节，
and I thought we did it pretty well back in Britain. But let's just say what Slovenia gets up to every December kind of blew us away. Like children in the U.S. or the U.K., Slovenian kids are visited by Santa Claus, every Christmas Eve. They call him Boziczek. These are the voices of kids that I recorded at my daughter Marnie's elementary school. And that's Marnie translating. But kids in Slovenia don't have to settle for just one center they also have a more traditional option available a Catholic saint called Miklausi who dishes out the gifts on the night of December the 5th. My clouch is a little kid. He likes him. My clouch because when you go to the show, he throws down sweeties and also brings presents.
我以为我们在英国时过得相当不错。但只能说，斯洛文尼亚每年十二月所做的一切让我们大开眼界。就像美国或英国的孩子一样，斯洛文尼亚的孩子们在每个平安夜都会收到圣诞老人的造访。他们称他为“博日切克”（Boziczek）。这些是我在我女儿玛妮的小学录下的孩子们的声音。那是玛妮在翻译。但斯洛文尼亚的孩子们不必只满足于一位圣诞老人，他们还有一个更传统的选择，一位名叫“米克劳什”（Miklausi）的天主教圣人，他在12月5日晚上分发礼物。米克劳什是个小家伙。他喜欢他。米克劳什，因为当你去看表演时，他会扔下糖果，还会带来礼物。
And if you're a kid in Slovenia, I think a G-s, too soon, it just really doesn't feel like enough. Well, don't worry. There is yet another option. He's a festive figure who comes down from the country's highest mountain every New Year's day to shower the children of Slovenia with good wishes and yet more presence. His name, if you didn't catch it, is Dedek Marass, grandpa Frost. I'm very glad I'm a papal choma. It's got a big beard and she's got a stick. I'm glad that it's more of a drill to do the camera. It was good, we did it right,
如果你是斯洛文尼亚的孩子，我想，天哪，太快了，这真的感觉不够。好吧，别担心。还有另一个选择。他是一位节日人物，每年元旦从该国最高的山上下来，向斯洛文尼亚的孩子们送去美好的祝愿和更多的礼物。他的名字，如果你没听清的话，是“杰德克·马拉兹”（Dedek Marass），即“严寒老人”（Grandpa Frost）。我很高兴我是个教皇。他有大胡子，还有一根棍子。我很高兴这更像是一个钻头来做摄像机。这很好，我们做得对，
because then we took a picture with him and had a fun time. If you're doing your sons, that means that this nation of just over 2 million people is visited by not one, not two, but three different Santas every festive season. As far as I know, they have the highest Santa Decidice and ratio of any country in the world. When I found out about Slovenia's three Santas, I had so many questions. Why was one Santa not enough for these people?
因为后来我们和他合了影，玩得很开心。如果你在算你的儿子们，这意味着这个拥有200多万人口的国家，每个节日季节都会迎来不止一位、两位，而是三位不同的圣诞老人。据我所知，他们拥有世界上最高的圣诞老人与人口比例。当我发现斯洛文尼亚有三位圣诞老人时，我有很多疑问。为什么对这些人来说，一位圣诞老人还不够呢？
Where on earth did they all come from and how do they manage to coexist? It turns out that each Santa has had his moment in the spotlight, each in a different period of Slovenia's complicated history. And today, if you want a Christmas season that reflects that history and speaks to all Slovenians, you need all three magical men. The people of Slovenia have long been protective of their customs and language, and you can understand why.
他们到底是从哪里来的，他们又是如何共存的？事实证明，每位圣诞老人都在斯洛文尼亚复杂的历史中，在不同的时期有过属于自己的高光时刻。今天，如果你想要一个反映那段历史并能与所有斯洛文尼亚人产生共鸣的圣诞季，你需要这三位神奇的人物。斯洛文尼亚人民长期以来一直保护着他们的习俗和语言，你可以理解为什么。
For hundreds of years, they were ruled by the Habsburg Empire, one of the most powerful dynasties in Europe. Their language superficially was German because they were part of the empire. That's art historian and self-described anglophone cheerleader of Slovenia, Noah Charni. But anyone living at home and going about their daily activities would have spoken Slovenian. And so that preservation of the language has helped keep them a relatively homogenous solid group despite all of the issues that plagued Europe over the past centuries. The Slevings were a distinct group of people with their own language but they
几百年来，他们一直受哈布斯堡帝国统治，这是欧洲最强大的王朝之一。他们的语言表面上是德语，因为他们是帝国的一部分。那是艺术史学家、自称斯洛文尼亚英语啦啦队长的诺亚·查尼。但任何在家里生活和进行日常活动的人都会说斯洛文尼亚语。因此，这种对语言的保护帮助他们保持为一个相对同质的稳固群体，尽管过去几个世纪欧洲饱受各种问题困扰。斯洛文尼亚人是一个独特的群体，有自己的语言，但他们
did share the same religion with almost all other subjects of the Hapsburg Empire, Roman Catholicism. Roman Catholics loved their saints, and around Christmas time, there was only one saint that mattered. Interest Slovenia's first magical Christmas man, St. Nicholas. St. Nicholas, or Sveti McLeodshin's Slovenia, was a bishop born in the third century's CE. There are a lot of stories that surround St. Nicholas. Some of them very gory and uncrismacy, but the one that matters for our purposes is about
确实与哈布斯堡帝国的所有其他臣民拥有相同的宗教，即罗马天主教。罗马天主教徒热爱他们的圣人，在圣诞节前后，只有一位圣人最重要。这就是斯洛文尼亚的第一位神奇圣诞老人，圣尼古拉斯。圣尼古拉斯，或斯洛文尼亚语中的“斯维蒂·米克劳什”（Sveti Miklaush），是一位出生于公元三世纪的主教。围绕圣尼古拉斯的故事有很多。其中一些非常血腥且不符合圣诞气氛，但对我们而言重要的是关于
a poor old man who got so desperate he was about to sell his daughters into prostitution. St. Nicholas intervened by delivering bags of gold coins to the man's house in the middle of the night. St. Nick coming in with an extremely intense origin story. And his St. day on to Samus 6 is when Slovenian children traditionally received presents while they were sleeping, just like those bags of gold one and a half millennia ago. But the action really happened the night before during Miklaus Vagnier, St. Nicholas Eve. In the capital of Vienna there was a church-sp parade with Maclaus at the center dressed like a Catholic bishop with that iconic pointed hat, golden slippers, and a curling
一位贫穷的老人，他绝望到差点要把女儿卖去当妓女。圣尼古拉斯在深夜往那人的房子里送去了几袋金币，从而进行了干预。圣尼古拉斯带着一个极其强烈的起源故事登场了。他的圣日是12月6日，这是斯洛文尼亚孩子们传统上在睡觉时收到礼物的时候，就像一千五百年前那些金币袋一样。但真正的行动发生在前一天晚上，即“米克劳什之夜”（Miklaus Vagnier），也就是圣尼古拉斯前夜。在首都维也纳，有一场教堂游行，米克劳什是中心人物，他打扮得像一位天主教主教，戴着标志性的尖顶帽，穿着金拖鞋，拿着弯曲的
bishop staff. St. Nicholas in the Slovenian tradition is kindly, but he's accompanied by a group of little demons called Parclinni. And their role is essentially as a tool to be used by parents to frighten children into being obedient. And these Parclinni, these demons are supposed to carry around clanking chains
主教权杖。斯洛文尼亚传统中的圣尼古拉斯是仁慈的，但他由一群被称为“帕克里尼”（Parclinni）的小恶魔陪伴。他们的角色本质上是父母用来吓唬孩子以使其听话的工具。而这些帕克里尼，这些恶魔，被要求带着叮当作响的锁链，
that they drag you off with. That is intensely swirky for our Christmas story. Yeah, Mikhail Ashtovaniy really knocks Halloween into a cocked hat. Some of the people I spoke to were genuinely traumatized by it because in rural areas, people would actually dress up as these demons and take the opportunity to torment local children. Mikhail Astervaniy was Slovenia's only Santa for generations, until the 1940s, when the country traded one empire for another and swapped centers in the process.
他们用锁链把你拖走。这对于我们的圣诞故事来说是非常诡异的。是的，“米克劳什之夜”确实让万圣节相形见绌。我交谈过的一些人对此感到真正的创伤，因为在农村地区，人们真的会打扮成这些恶魔，并借机折磨当地的孩子。几代人以来，“米克劳什之夜”一直是斯洛文尼亚唯一的圣诞老人，直到20世纪40年代，这个国家用一个帝国换了另一个帝国，并在此过程中更换了圣诞老人。
When the Austro-Hungarian Empire crumbled after World War I, the Slevinge peoples decided to join a collection of six nations who identified themselves ethnically as southern or Yugo Slavs. Yugoslavia was born. At first Yugoslavia was a monarchy, but after World War II it became a communist country led by a charismatic strong man named Josep Braz, better known as Tito. Under Tito, Catholicism was suppressed and St. Nicholas aka McClausch was banned. So after World War II, the new Yugoslav communist authorities wanted to banish religious customs from public life and they wanted to replace them with the new, let's say, socialist holidays. That's Nina Gido, a curator at the Slovenian ethnographic museum who has researched this
当奥匈帝国在第一次世界大战后崩溃时，斯洛文尼亚人民决定加入六个民族的集合，他们从民族上认同自己为南方斯拉夫人或南斯拉夫人。南斯拉夫诞生了。起初，南斯拉夫是一个君主制国家，但二战后，它变成了一个由一位名叫约瑟普·布罗兹（Josip Broz，更广为人知的名字是铁托）的魅力型强人领导的共产主义国家。在铁托统治下，天主教受到压制，圣尼古拉斯（又名米克劳什）被禁止。所以二战后，新的南斯拉夫共产主义当局想要从公共生活中消除宗教习俗，他们想用新的、比如说，社会主义节日来取代它们。这是斯洛文尼亚民族学博物馆的策展人尼娜·吉多（Nina Gido）所说的，她研究过这个
period. And I must say that I even met one man. He was playing the role on Sam Nikolas and then the police came. And he told to me that he was in the prison for two days because of playing the role of Sam Nikolas. because of playing the role of San Nicolas. Burning dressing up as a Catholic saint was one thing, but taking away presents for children during the darkest month of the year would have been unforgivable. Tito knew that, and so he needed something, or rather someone,
时期。我必须说，我甚至见过一个人。他当时正在扮演圣尼古拉斯的角色，然后警察来了。他告诉我，因为扮演圣尼古拉斯的角色，他在监狱里待了两天。因为扮演圣尼古拉斯的角色。打扮成天主教圣人是一回事，但在一年中最黑暗的月份剥夺孩子们的礼物是不可原谅的。铁托知道这一点，所以他需要某种东西，或者更确切地说是某个人，
to take Maclauch's place. Exit Maclauch, enter our next magical Christmas man. At this point Yugoslavia relied on the Soviet Union for economic assistance, and Tito decided to borrow from its culture too. Since the 1930s, the Soviet Union had deployed a communist center to hand out the gifts. And that figure is called in Russian dead mortals or grandfather Frost in Slovenia he's called Dedek Miraz. Dedek Miraz looked like an enormous bearded man from the Russian countryside. We would appear in factories and if we're being pragmatic he was probably someone from the factory team dressed up. The
来取代米克劳什。米克劳什退场，我们的下一位神奇圣诞老人登场。此时，南斯拉夫在经济援助上依赖苏联，铁托决定也借鉴其文化。自20世纪30年代以来，苏联就部署了一位共产主义圣诞老人来分发礼物。那个形象在俄语中被称为“杰德·莫罗兹”（Ded Moroz），即“严寒老人”。在斯洛文尼亚，他被称为“杰德克·马拉兹”（Dedek Miraz）。杰德克·马拉兹看起来像一个来自俄罗斯乡村的巨大胡子男人。我们会出现在工厂里，如果我们务实一点的话，他可能就是工厂团队里打扮的人。
children would come to the factory and then they would have this positive association with going to the factory and then they would have this positive association with going to the factory and the parents would feel that the factory was the one giving the gifts to their children. And it's this good communist alternative to Catholic St. Nicholas or capitalist Santa Claus. But a political crisis threatened to end, Dedic Morass, before he had even had a chance to spread the holiday cheer. Joseph Stalin wanted Yugoslavia to become a puppet state for the Soviet Union, but Tito was having none of it.
孩子们会来到工厂，然后他们会对去工厂产生这种积极的联想，父母们会觉得是工厂在给他们的孩子送礼物。这是对天主教圣尼古拉斯或资本主义圣诞老人的一个很好的共产主义替代品。但一场政治危机威胁要在“杰德克·马拉兹”甚至还没来得及传播节日欢乐之前就终结他。约瑟夫·斯大林想让南斯拉夫成为苏联的傀儡国，但铁托对此毫不买账。
And Stalin didn't take kindly to Tito's independent streak. There is clear evidence that Stalin tried to have him assassinated on at least 20 different occasions, including with such James Bond-like gadgetry as a music box that released nerve gas. Tito eventually outlawed all Soviet influence in Yugoslavia, but he wanted to keep Dedek Miraz, just not dressed like a Russian.
斯大林对铁托的独立倾向并不友好。有明确证据表明，斯大林曾试图在至少20个不同场合暗杀他，包括使用像詹姆斯·邦德那样的小玩意，比如一个会释放神经毒气的音乐盒。铁托最终取缔了南斯拉夫境内所有的苏联影响，但他想保留“杰德克·马拉兹”，只是不想让他打扮得像个俄罗斯人。
He wanted to, you know, you just love him up a bit. But Tito's initial attempts were a little haphazard. Over the next few chrysances, Grandpa Frost appeared dressed up as a soldier, a minor, a sailor, even a striking worker, basically socialist archetypes of Yugoslav proletarian heroes. Yeah, at the beginning it was quite political, like the Dukmeras was bringing the greetings from Tito. But neither the original recipe Russian Dachmeras or the Yugoslavian cosplay version really caught on in Slovenia. The people just didn't buy it, it felt phony and so Tito decided to
他想，你知道，稍微让他本土化一点。但铁托最初的尝试有点杂乱无章。在接下来的几个圣诞节里，“严寒老人”打扮成士兵、矿工、水手，甚至罢工工人，基本上是南斯拉夫无产阶级英雄的社会主义原型。是的，起初这相当政治化，就像“杰德克·马拉兹”在传达来自铁托的问候。但无论是原版的俄罗斯“严寒老人”还是南斯拉夫的Cosplay版本，在斯洛文尼亚都没有真正流行起来。人们根本不买账，感觉很虚假，所以铁托决定
allow each of the six Yugoslav nations, including Slovenia, to design their own bespoke version of Grandpa Frost. In Slovenia, this country that had long been a part of a bigger empire, took the opportunity to redesign Detic Maras and turn him into something distinctly Slovenian. A 69-year-old painter called Maxine Gaspari was brought in to handle the design. This was a genius decision because although Gaspari was brought in to handle the design. This was a genius decision because although Gaspari was a classically trained artist, he was first and foremost a commercial illustrator with a broad fanbase. I think of him as a Slovenian Norman Rockwell. And when it came to Christmas, Gaspari knew what would appeal to as many Slovenians as possible. He tends to be known
允许包括斯洛文尼亚在内的六个南斯拉夫国家中的每一个，设计他们自己定制版的“严寒老人”。在斯洛文尼亚，这个长期作为大帝国一部分的国家，借此机会重新设计了“杰德克·马拉兹”，并将他变成了一个具有鲜明斯洛文尼亚特色的人物。一位名叫马克西姆·加斯帕里（Maxine Gaspari）的69岁画家被请来负责设计。这是一个天才的决定，因为虽然加斯帕里是受过古典训练的艺术家，但他首先是一位拥有广泛粉丝群的商业插画家。我认为他是斯洛文尼亚的诺曼·洛克威尔。说到圣诞节，加斯帕里知道什么最能吸引尽可能多的斯洛文尼亚人。他往往被
to the general public because he did this series of paintings that were made into postcards and collectibles of folk scenes related to the Christmas holiday. They're very tweey now, but this was the Christmas aesthetic that people would be used to in Slovenia. In 1952, Kasparri created three postcards of his new updated Slovenian version of Dedek Maras.
大众所熟知，因为他创作了一系列被制成明信片和收藏品的与圣诞节相关的民间场景画作。它们现在看起来很矫情，但这却是斯洛文尼亚人习惯的圣诞美学。1952年，加斯帕里创作了三张他新更新的斯洛文尼亚版“杰德克·马拉兹”的明信片。
He's smoking an old-fashioned decorated pipe that is associated with this one small town in the mountains. He's got a long sheepskin coat with these ancient Slovenian flower motifs on the coat tails, and he's got a hat made out of doormouse for her. Doormice were one of the few sources of protein available to the rural poor, and it takes a lot of doormice to make a hat. And Dedek Muros is like that. He is a trapper who hunts doormice. He is not wealthy, but what wealthy has, he shares by bringing gifts to children.
他抽着一种与山区一个小镇相关的老式装饰烟斗。他穿着一件长羊皮大衣，大衣下摆有古老的斯洛文尼亚花卉图案，他还戴着一顶用睡鼠皮做的帽子。睡鼠是农村穷人仅有的几种蛋白质来源之一，做一顶帽子需要很多睡鼠。而“杰德克·马拉兹”就是这样。他是一个猎捕睡鼠的捕兽者。他不富有，但他把拥有的财富通过给孩子们带来礼物而分享出去。
Sluvenian fairy tales are full of modest and humble heroes who rise to the challenge when needed. Mountain men ready to answer the call. So Gospari was making sure that his dead egg morais spoke directly to the character of the people. A voluntary organization called the Association of Friends of Youth was in charge of the Deadic Marass rollout. They made ten identical costumes from Gaspar's designs, and in 1952 the new Deadic Marass made appearances in and around the capital. This was followed by a booklet called Deadic Marass Prehaya. Deadic Marass is coming in 1957.
斯洛文尼亚童话故事里充满了谦逊而卑微的英雄，他们在需要时挺身而出。山里人随时准备响应号召。所以加斯帕里确保了他的“杰德克·马拉兹”直接诉诸于人民的性格。一个名为“青年之友协会”的志愿者组织负责“杰德克·马拉兹”的推广。他们根据加斯帕里的设计制作了十套一模一样的服装，1952年，新的“杰德克·马拉兹”在首都及周边地区亮相。随后出现了一本名为《杰德克·马拉兹来了》（Dedek Marass Prehaya）的小册子，即1957年的《杰德克·马拉兹来了》。
The booklet had one main instruction. Deadic Marass was a fairy tale figure designed only for kids. He wasn't a piece of state propaganda the way Stalin or Tito had treated him. He was fun. Translated into English, the booklet said, that Derek Marass is not a didactic figure, but a lively, cheerful, witty, fairy tale figure that sinks into the child's world, so that child comes to life with it. And it seems to have worked.
这本小册子有一个主要说明。“杰德克·马拉兹”是一个专为孩子们设计的童话人物。他不是斯大林或铁托所对待的那种国家宣传工具。他很有趣。翻译成英文，小册子上说，“杰德克·马拉兹”不是一个说教的人物，而是一个生动、开朗、风趣、童话般的人物，他融入了孩子的世界，让孩子随之活跃起来。这似乎奏效了。
I believe that Eddickmas was real, but I was younger. This is my friend Yasna. She was a child of the Slovenian 70s and 80s and grew up with the distinctly Slovenian Eddickmas. You know, because you really saw him, because he came to kindergarten. He was not a fictional character, you know, that you see it only in on TV or just hear stories about him or, you know, he will come during night and no, he came in during day, he came to you. He gave you his hand, he hugged you, so it was a real person.
我相信“杰德克·马拉兹”是真实的，但我当时更年轻。这是我的朋友亚斯娜。她是斯洛文尼亚70年代和80年代的孩子，是在有着鲜明斯洛文尼亚特色的“杰德克·马拉兹”陪伴下长大的。你知道，因为你真的见到了他，因为他来到了幼儿园。他不是一个虚构的人物，你知道，你只在电视上看到他，或者只是听到关于他的故事，或者，你知道，他会在晚上来，不，他是白天来的，他来到你身边。他握住你的手，拥抱你，所以他是一个真实的人。
And it gets better, because they also hired one of the greatest writers of children's songs in Slovenia, Janis Beatens, to give Dedek Maras his own catchy theme song. Siva, kuc, má, bela, brada. I don't remember the words. Just a second. I don't remember the words. Just a second. Here it is. Great Hat, White Beard, Warm Coat, Full Basket. Oh, he's already come among us. Good old deadig morass.
而且情况变得更好，因为他们还聘请了斯洛文尼亚最伟大的儿童歌曲作家之一，亚尼斯·贝滕斯（Janis Beatens），为“杰德克·马拉兹”创作了他自己朗朗上口的同名主题曲。白帽子，白胡子，暖和的大衣，满满的篮子。哦，他已经来到我们中间了。好老头“杰德克·马拉兹”。
Red Bulls, Books, Notebooks, Dolls, Sleds and more. Oh, he's already come among us. Good old dead emeras. Yeah, maybe say sort of hello to listeners in America on dead emeras. In English or in Slovenia? Slovenian, why not? Hey, pozdrauljeni drubiš. This Jolly Fellow is Robert Valtel. He started playing Dead in Marass at the main parade in L'Abiana in 1987. Robert is quite a character in his own right. We talk for hours in his apartment,
红球、书、笔记本、玩偶、雪橇等等。哦，他已经来到我们中间了。好老头“杰德克·马拉兹”。是的，也许对美国的听众说声你好，用“杰德克·马拉兹”的身份。用英语还是斯洛文尼亚语？斯洛文尼亚语，为什么不呢？嘿，大家好。这位快乐的家伙是罗伯特·瓦尔特尔（Robert Valtel）。他于1987年开始在卢布尔雅那的主要游行中扮演“杰德克·马拉兹”。罗伯特本人就是一个很有个性的人。我们在他的公寓里聊了几个小时，
alongside the love of his life, his dog Umbra. OK, Umbra, Mir de Iprosim. Mir, what breed is Umbra? L'agoto Romanieolo, Italian water dog. Fancy. Yeah, fancy, fancy. When Robert started performing as Deleg Marasse, Tito had been dead for seven years,
和他一生的挚爱，他的狗翁布拉（Umbra）在一起。好的，翁布拉，请安静。安静，翁布拉是什么品种？拉戈托罗马格诺罗犬，意大利水犬。时髦。是的，时髦，时髦。当罗伯特开始扮演“杰德克·马拉兹”时，铁托已经去世七年了，
and Yugoslavia was on a downward spiral to complete the integration. But Slovenia was actually doing well economically and felt that the other republics were dragging her down. So in 1991 Slovenians took their chances and declared independence from Yugoslavia. And it was fantastic. It was really fantastic because it was like almost everyone for the independence. Jasna remembers this period feeling almost too good to be true. Yeah, it was scary a little bit because we knew that they wouldn't let us go, that easy. So it was exciting and also you didn't know what will happen. And then when it happened, it was like Everything at once.
南斯拉夫正处于彻底解体的下行螺旋中。但斯洛文尼亚当时的经济表现实际上很好，并觉得其他共和国在拖累它。因此，在1991年，斯洛文尼亚人抓住机会，宣布脱离南斯拉夫独立。这太棒了。这真的太棒了，因为几乎每个人都支持独立。亚斯娜记得这段时期感觉好得几乎不真实。是的，有点吓人，因为我们知道他们不会那么轻易让我们走。所以这很令人兴奋，而且你不知道会发生什么。然后当它发生时，就像一切都在瞬间发生。
On June 24th, Robert and a group of actor friends were performing all over the capital. He still vividly remembers how happy everyone was in the hours leading up to Slovenia's formal declaration of independence. It was beautiful in Dubljana, everywhere, you know, happy people. So, and then we went to sleep, I don't know, four or five morning and then start the alarm for the bumps. So that was really shocked. The Yugoslav Air Force dropped five and it's in Tannen, that Slovenian militia targets throughout the day. But the war only lasted 10 days. Slovenia
6月24日，罗伯特和一群演员朋友在首都各地表演。他仍然生动地记得在斯洛文尼亚正式宣布独立前的几个小时里，每个人是多么快乐。卢布尔雅那到处都很美，你知道，人们都很开心。所以，然后我们去睡觉了，我不知道，凌晨四五点，然后警报响了，开始有爆炸声。所以那真的很震惊。南斯拉夫空军全天向斯洛文尼亚民兵目标投下了五枚炸弹。但战争只持续了10天。斯洛文尼亚
escaped the horror that befell many of the other former Yugoslav nations throughout the 1990s. What's happened in Croatia first and Bosnia it's horrible. It's really horrible. But for Slovenia we were lucky. Of the centuries of being part of monocles, empires, and failed six-part nation-states, Slovenia had achieved independence in under two weeks. But this victory led to a battle over Slovenian culture, one that almost spelled the end for We were afraid that the Dereck-Mras can disappear.
逃脱了20世纪90年代许多其他前南斯拉夫国家所遭受的恐怖。克罗地亚先发生的事情，还有波斯尼亚，太可怕了。这真的很可怕。但对于斯洛文尼亚，我们很幸运。在经历了几个世纪作为君主制、帝国和失败的六部分民族国家的一部分后，斯洛文尼亚在不到两周的时间内就实现了独立。但这场胜利导致了一场关于斯洛文尼亚文化的斗争，一场差点让“杰德克·马拉兹”终结的斗争。我们担心“杰德克·马拉兹”会消失。
Because some people, they want you to know to kill him. Many Slovenes saw this moment as an opportunity to move into the modern world and reject everything from the past. And despite his fun Slovenian rebrand, some people still associated dead in Miras with the Soviet Union. But what was really funny? They want to replace him with Santa Claus. Inter Slovenia's third magical Christmas man, Santa Claus. The red suit wearing reindeer having rosy cheek jolly fellow that you probably are picturing right now thanks in part to the Coca-Cola Company. Their Christmas character was designed to be used in coca-ads starting in 1931, and like the beverage itself, their Santa Amage went nearly everywhere in the capitalist world.
因为有些人，他们想让你知道，要杀了他。许多斯洛文尼亚人将这一时刻视为进入现代世界并拒绝过去一切的机会。尽管他有有趣的斯洛文尼亚品牌重塑，但有些人仍然将“杰德克·马拉兹”与苏联联系在一起。但真正有趣的是什么？他们想用圣诞老人来取代他。斯洛文尼亚的第三位神奇圣诞老人，圣诞老人登场。那个穿着红西装、带着驯鹿、脸颊红润、快乐的家伙，你现在可能正在脑海中浮现，这在一定程度上要归功于可口可乐公司。他们的圣诞人物设计于1931年开始用于可乐广告，就像饮料本身一样，他们的圣诞老人形象几乎传遍了整个资本主义世界。
And suddenly, Slovenia was a democratic capitalist-friendly country, and looking to America and looking to Western Europe and hoping for a brighter, more independent economic future. Well, if you're interested in economic futures and capitalism, then you want your Santa wearing red pajamas and bringing as many gifts as possible. Many Slovenians embraced Santa Claus, but this time the new Santa didn't push the old one off the stage. In the end, Dedek Moraz survived the transition from socialist Yugoslavia to democratic Slovenia. It's hard to say exactly why, but I can't help wonder if it's because he was so well designed. Even though he was a relatively new creation, Dedek Miras was crafted to feel like he'd always been there, like he was an ancient artifact of Slovenian culture.
突然间，斯洛文尼亚成为了一个民主的、对资本主义友好的国家，并向美国和西欧寻求更光明、更独立的经济未来。好吧，如果你对经济未来和资本主义感兴趣，那么你会希望你的圣诞老人穿着红睡衣，尽可能多地带来礼物。许多斯洛文尼亚人拥抱了圣诞老人，但这一次，新的圣诞老人并没有把旧的赶下台。最终，“杰德克·马拉兹”在从社会主义南斯拉夫到民主斯洛文尼亚的过渡中幸存了下来。很难说确切原因，但我忍不住想，这是否因为他设计得太好了。尽管他是一个相对较新的创造，“杰德克·马拉兹”被精心打造得让人感觉他一直都在那里，就像他是斯洛文尼亚文化的古老文物一样。
And people like Gazna weren't going to let him go without a fight. It's still a part of our history. Why kill it? I grew up with it. I didn't grow up with Santa Claus. The rest is a part of us. So no way.
像亚斯娜这样的人不会不战而降就让他离开。这仍然是我们历史的一部分。为什么要杀了他？我是伴随着他长大的。我不是伴随着圣诞老人长大的。其余部分是我们的一部分。所以没门。
Totally, no way. So, no way. So, it's in no way. Dagmaras and Sena Claus were side by side, sharing the Christmas spotlight, and that would have been enough for most countries. But there was a sleeping giant in this story, our first magical Christmas man who had never really gone away.
完全没门。所以，没门。所以，这绝不可能。“杰德克·马拉兹”和圣诞老人并肩作战，分享着圣诞聚光灯，这对大多数国家来说已经足够了。但这个故事里有一个沉睡的巨人，我们第一位从未真正离开过的神奇圣诞老人。
Sveti Miklausch, the original Catholic St. Nick. While the government had banned public religious celebrations in the Yugoslav era, Catholic families still held festivities in private. Yeah, so after the independence, all these customs connected with the religion, they were again introduced in the public life. So San Nicolas came back. And Robert Valtel, Lubbiana's go-to Detic Maraz, actually played a key role in the cloud she's returned. He believed that if Slovenia was to move on, it had to reconcile its past as a faithful Catholic nation. When you show that they can be together,
斯维蒂·米克劳什，最初的天主教圣尼古拉斯。虽然政府在南斯拉夫时代禁止了公共宗教庆祝活动，但天主教家庭仍然在私下举行庆祝活动。是的，所以在独立后，所有这些与宗教相关的习俗又被重新引入了公共生活。所以圣尼古拉斯回来了。而卢布尔雅那的“杰德克·马拉兹”首选罗伯特·瓦尔特尔，实际上在米克劳什的回归中发挥了关键作用。他相信，如果斯洛文尼亚要继续前进，它就必须调和其作为忠实天主教国家的过去。当你展示他们可以共存时，
suny colors and grandpa throws the decmaras and that they can both say something nice and do something nice, it's a beautiful. And so in 1991, Robert, already the capitals go to De decmaras, decided to organize a parade from Mikklaush. It was the first one since the Second World War, the Saints' grand return to public life. Never shying away from a challenge, Robert decided to play the central role of Mikklaush himself.
圣尼古拉斯和“严寒老人”杰德克·马拉兹，他们都可以说些好话，做些好事，这很美。因此，在1991年，已经是首都“杰德克·马拉兹”首选的罗伯特决定组织一场为米克劳什举行的游行。这是自二战以来的第一次，圣人重返公共生活。从不回避挑战的罗伯特决定亲自扮演米克劳什的核心角色。
You know, for me this is theatre, and when I work theatre I want to do perfection. To get into character, only the most authentic costume for Sveti McLeosh would do. I ask the bishop of Rubljana to rent me original, old, you know, Catholic bishop stuff, and I was really beautiful, even with the golden shoes. And ever since that moment, when Maclaus returned the streets of the capital, Slovenia has had all three centers at Christmas time.
你知道，对我来说这是戏剧，当我做戏剧时，我想要完美。为了进入角色，只有最正宗的斯维蒂·米克劳什服装才行。我请卢布尔雅那的主教租给我原始的、古老的，你知道，天主教主教权杖，这真的很美，甚至还有金色的鞋子。从那一刻起，当米克劳什回到首都街头时，斯洛文尼亚在圣诞节期间就有了三位圣诞老人。
And Slovenes have not only completely accepted all the three good men, Trigdobri Moseje, they've been packaged together in a month of non-stop festivities called Mary of Vaselli December. Vaselli December. It's the whole month, you know. It's like the month of the parties and happy stuff. And that's why we have all three men because it's the whole month of good and merry stuff. Each Santa gets its own specific time slot to perform their own brand of Christmas magic. First on the calendar is Maclaus.
斯洛文尼亚人不仅完全接受了这三位好人（Trigdobri Moseje），他们还被打包在一起，在一个月内进行不间断的庆祝活动，称为“快乐的十二月”（Mary of Vaselli December）。快乐的十二月。这是一个整月，你知道。这就像是派对和快乐事物的月份。这就是为什么我们有这三个人，因为这是一个充满美好和快乐事物的整月。每位圣诞老人都有自己特定的时间段来表演他们自己品牌的圣诞魔法。日历上的第一位是米克劳什。
Here appears at churches across the country and parades in the big cities on the evening of December the 5th. I took my family to this parade in 2018. My daughter loved Maclaus, but she didn't react too well when his demon helpers first appeared. Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God!
他于12月5日晚上出现在全国各地的教堂和各大城市的游行中。2018年我带家人参加了这个游行。我女儿很喜欢米克劳什，但当他的恶魔助手第一次出现时，她的反应不太好。我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！
Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God!
我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！
Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh my God! That's a lot of screaming inter, for a Santa parade. Then comes Santa Claus or Bozycheck. Christmas Eve is obviously his allotted night,
我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！我的天啊！对于一个圣诞老人游行来说，这尖叫声也太多了。接下来是圣诞老人或“博日切克”。平安夜显然是他分配到的夜晚，
but he tends to hang around the shops and malls. And finally, there's Dedek Moras. He actually makes appearances in kindergarten and schools throughout December, but post Christmas time, he's the only Santa left on the scene. His parade happens around New Year's. I met performers of all three centres, including Robert, and they take their jobs extremely seriously. This is not carneval. This is something very important for children.
但他往往会在商店和商场周围徘徊。最后是“杰德克·马拉兹”。他实际上在整个十二月都会在幼儿园和学校露面，但圣诞节过后，他是现场唯一剩下的圣诞老人。他的游行发生在新年左右。我见过所有三位圣诞老人的表演者，包括罗伯特，他们非常认真地对待自己的工作。这不是狂欢节。这对孩子们来说是非常重要的事情。
Helping children is fundamental to Robert's role in the Slovenian Christmas, but it's not always easy. So the children, they're not all happy. They're not living all in happy families. And when they see, they have opportunity to speak with the de-chmraz. They can say a lot of settings from, you know, their lives. Kids ask you for help, like my father, bit my mother, he's an alcoholic, please, did a mask and I stay with you. I don't want to go home. That's really difficult. That's really difficult. I Normally, I'm not social worker. I cannot really help to them. Yeah, it's it's a lot of
帮助孩子是罗伯特在斯洛文尼亚圣诞节角色中的根本，但这并不总是容易的。所以孩子们，他们并不都快乐。他们并不都生活在幸福的家庭里。当他们看到，他们有机会与“杰德克·马拉兹”交谈时。他们可以说出很多生活中的烦恼。孩子们向你寻求帮助，比如我父亲，打了我母亲，他是个酒鬼，请，“杰德克·马拉兹”，我能和你待在一起吗？我不想回家。这真的很困难。这真的很困难。我通常不是社会工作者。我真的无法帮助他们。是的，这背后也有很多
frustrations also behind this because how to really help? Robert's response really moved me. I always thought dressing up as a Santa would be an almost entirely wonderful experience, but it's clear that there's also this feeling of a real responsibility. All of the Santas are supposed to provide comfort to the kids of Slovenia, but according to Robert, its deadic morass they tend to most, the Santa designed for the Slovenian people by the Slovenian people. Today, almost no one thinks the Dekmraz came from Soviet Union because we make completely new story.
挫折，因为如何真正提供帮助？罗伯特的回答真的感动了我。我一直认为打扮成圣诞老人会是一种几乎完全美妙的体验，但很明显，这也有一种真正的责任感。所有的圣诞老人本应为斯洛文尼亚的孩子们提供安慰，但据罗伯特说，他们最倾向于“杰德克·马拉兹”，这是由斯洛文尼亚人民为斯洛文尼亚人民设计的圣诞老人。今天，几乎没有人认为“杰德克·马拉兹”来自苏联，因为我们创造了一个全新的故事。
Slovenia has survived empires and a socialist autocracy to emerge as a proud independent state. Instead of repressing the past, it has embraced the Santas that once defined it, coordinating a festive season that has a time and a place for all of them. One last question. How long are you going to be Telegmaras? And who will you hand it on to?
斯洛文尼亚在帝国和社会主义独裁统治下幸存下来，成为了一个自豪的独立国家。它没有压制过去，而是拥抱了曾经定义它的圣诞老人，协调了一个为他们所有人提供时间和地点的节日季节。最后一个问题。你要当多久的“杰德克·马拉兹”？你会把它传给谁？
How long I will be Telegmaras? Who knows? I will try my best but it's the paint of my health so I already have some my colleagues they can replace me and this will be this will continue for sure. Yeah, the decmaras will live forever. Thank you. We are coming up after the break, we find out which of Slovenia's three centers is the most popular of all. So I'm back with Porter, Will Aspinol. And well, I just want to ask you a little bit more about how the Sanchez operate in Slovenian society. When we talk about how they divide up the month of December,
我会当多久的“杰德克·马拉兹”？谁知道呢？我会尽我所能，但这是我健康的痛苦，所以我已经有一些同事可以取代我，这肯定会继续下去。是的，“杰德克·马拉兹”将永远活下去。谢谢。休息后回来，我们将找出斯洛文尼亚的三位圣诞老人中哪一位最受欢迎。所以我又回到了记者威尔·阿斯佩纳身边。那么，我只是想多问你一点关于圣诞老人在斯洛文尼亚社会中是如何运作的。当我们谈论他们如何划分十二月时，
but does everyone celebrate each of them equally or do some of these political and religious factions that's recreated them sort of extend into today? Like how does it really work with your average family? Yeah, you can see that these three Santas do represent of three tribes. If you like, McClouch goes with the Catholic faithful, Deedick Rouse with old school socialists and Santa Claus with, you know, the new coming aspirational consumers. But it's not quite as simple as that, you know, many
每个人是否平等地庆祝他们每个人，或者创造他们的那些政治和宗教派别是否延伸到了今天？比如，对于普通家庭来说，这到底是怎么运作的？是的，你可以看到这三位圣诞老人确实代表了三个部落。如果你愿意的话，米克劳什与天主教信徒同行，“杰德克·马拉兹”与老派社会主义者同行，而圣诞老人则与，你知道，新来的有抱负的消费者同行。但这并不像那样简单，你知道，许多
parents with young children will opt for all three, some will opt for one or two. I mean, my friend Yasner, and when I asked her this question, she explained to me how each of the three centers functioned in her life. Now she comes from a coastal town called Copa, near Italy. The coast was more communist, red area, let's say, and we have only dead thickness, although we knew Santa Claus because of Italy, because of the border, because they had Santa Claus. So after independence in 1991, she moved north to the mountains close to the border with Austria, and then she married and had two kids. And as a parent, she welcomes all three sounders as a way of celebrating Mary December with both sides of the family. And usually we went for Christmas in copper and from for the new year we were here. So in copper came Santa Claus and
有小孩的父母会选择全部三个，有些人会选择一个或两个。我的意思是，我的朋友亚斯娜，当我问她这个问题时，她向我解释了这三位圣诞老人每个人在她的生活中是如何运作的。她来自靠近意大利的一个叫科佩尔的沿海城镇。海岸更共产主义，红色区域，可以说，我们只有“杰德克·马拉兹”，尽管因为意大利，因为边界，因为他们有圣诞老人，我们知道圣诞老人。所以1991年独立后，她搬到了靠近奥地利边境的山区，然后她结婚并有了两个孩子。作为一名家长，她欢迎所有三位圣诞老人，作为与家庭双方庆祝“快乐的十二月”的一种方式。通常我们去科佩尔过圣诞节，新年我们就在这里。所以在科佩尔来了圣诞老人，
here came the decmaras and okay me claus it was only for fruit and sweets, no toys. So we had also this, we have all three. So someone clout to stuck with fruits and sweets, no toys. So how are you raising your kids? Like all three Sanas in their lives? I'm afraid it's totally unavoidable. It was Michael Giovanni last night. So this this morning they received their stockings from Mickalash, and that's a new thing for them, which they have totally, they're very happy with, indeed, when they got a stuffed toy, they got a tangerine chocolate shaped like the devils and Mickalash, and a new book. But we also have, obviously, we we have Father Christmas as we call him in
这里来了“杰德克·马拉兹”，好吧，米克劳什只送水果和糖果，没有玩具。所以我们也有这个，我们有全部三个。所以米克劳什只送水果和糖果，没有玩具。那么你是怎么抚养你的孩子的？比如他们生活中有全部三位圣诞老人吗？恐怕这是完全不可避免的。昨晚是“米克劳什之夜”。所以今天早上他们收到了来自米克劳什的袜子，这对他们来说是一件新鲜事，他们对此非常高兴，确实，当他们得到一个毛绒玩具时，他们得到了一个形状像恶魔和米克劳什的橘子巧克力，还有一本新书。但我们显然也有，我们有圣诞老人，正如我们在
the UK Santa Claus Christmas Eve that he's coming up. Denik Miras actually we haven't been in the country for New Year's Eve. So we need to give that a go this year. Oh so is Denik Miras coming to your house or to the kindergarten? It's still a bit of white and sea with the pandemic this year, but actually I track down the guy who is the Dellic Marass in our area. He's a wonderful man called Grega Antolin. All three centers will survive because they are super heroes and we need super heroes. Before the pandemic, he would make his living doing live performances in Ken Gardens all over December.
英国所称的那样，圣诞老人平安夜他要来了。“杰德克·马拉兹”实际上我们新年夜不在国内。所以我们今年需要尝试一下。哦，所以“杰德克·马拉兹”是来你家还是去幼儿园？今年因为疫情还有点观望，但我实际上追踪到了我们地区扮演“杰德克·马拉兹”的那个人。他是一个很棒的人，叫格雷加·安托林（Grega Antolin）。所有三位圣诞老人都会幸存下来，因为他们是超级英雄，我们需要超级英雄。疫情之前，他会在整个十二月在幼儿园做现场表演来谋生。
Yeah, there are other jobs during the rest of the year. But obviously, with the pandemic in 2020, with the lockdown that we had, he had to think fast. Before Corona, we make in December live performances. And now we must do something new because we were at home. His genius plan was that he would do an online videogram service for Slovenian kids. It was inspired by a US Santa graham video messaging service that he saw. And yeah, he decided to bring it to Slovenia. So, so, so, Sennagram is like a video message from Santa, two kids, and you said he plays
是的，一年中剩下的时间还有其他工作。但显然，随着2020年的疫情，随着我们经历的封锁，他必须快速思考。新冠之前，我们在十二月做现场表演。现在我们必须做一些新的事情，因为我们待在家里。他的天才计划是为斯洛文尼亚的孩子们提供在线视频服务。这灵感来自于他看到的美国圣诞老人视频信息服务。是的，他决定把它带到斯洛文尼亚。所以，所以，所以，圣诞老人信息就像是来自圣诞老人的视频信息，给孩子们，你说他在这些视频里扮演
Dedic Marass in these. Not just Dedic Marass. This is Slovenia, so he has to do all three. And that requires quite a little bit of financial outplay and planning because he needs not just three costumes, which are pretty expensive because I've seen them and they are the real deal. I mean, this Dedic Marass one was almost $2,000. Wow.
“杰德克·马拉兹”。不仅仅是“杰德克·马拉兹”。这是斯洛文尼亚，所以他必须扮演全部三个。这需要相当多的财务投入和计划，因为他不仅需要三套服装，这些服装非常昂贵，因为我见过它们，它们是真货。我的意思是，这个“杰德克·马拉兹”的服装几乎要2000美元。哇。
Custom made. He then has to do three different sets and then he records a different video with each of the most common children's names in Slovenia. To be recorded, 150 names of boys and 150 names from girls. This was the most common names in past two years. Okay, so 150 girls names, 150 boys names, that's 300 names for each Santa. So 300 times three is 900 names that he has to record
定制的。然后他必须做三套不同的布景，然后他用斯洛文尼亚最常见的每个孩子的名字录制不同的视频。要录制150个男孩的名字和150个女孩的名字。这是过去两年中最常见的名字。好的，所以150个女孩名字，150个男孩名字，那是每个圣诞老人300个名字。所以300乘以3就是900个名字，他必须录制
and it has to work first time. So imagine retakes. Wow, that's really a lot of work. And then I should say that the parents can choose their Santa and they can choose the name and then they can choose the message. And cleaning teeth is a very high priority for Slovenian parents. So this is the message that's Sando or MacLeod or Doug Marass has to say is to like be a good child this year and clean your teeth and then I'll bring your presents. Yeah, exactly. Classic. I really wish I really wish I could have seen it in person. I did pass to him,
而且必须一次成功。所以想象一下重拍。哇，那真的是很多工作。然后我应该说父母可以选择他们的圣诞老人，他们可以选择名字，然后他们可以选择信息。刷牙是斯洛文尼亚父母非常优先考虑的事情。所以这是圣诞老人或米克劳什或“杰德克·马拉兹”必须说的话，比如今年做一个好孩子，刷牙，然后我会给你带来礼物。是的，完全正确。经典。我真的希望我能亲眼看到它。我确实传给了他，
but it was a close set. You got to keep these things secret. I mean, this is magical stuff we're talking about here. He did very kindly send me some sneak peeks of his performance. So would you like to hear some? Oh, absolutely. Let's hear them. Okay, first up, Santa Claus. Ha-ha-ha! In my dreams, I see that life is so much better. To have time and time, we'll take a long time,
但这是一个封闭的场景。你必须对这些事情保密。我的意思是，我们在这里谈论的是神奇的东西。他确实非常友好地给我发了一些他表演的先睹为快。那么你想听听吗？哦，当然。让我们听听。好的，首先是圣诞老人。哈哈哈哈！在我的梦里，我看到生活好多了。有时间，有时间，需要很长时间，
if we have a long time to do it. Včeš, kako je vidno tako živahno, da učasih škrati kar pozabimo, kodila imamo in pakoliko da riliša za zaviti. Meneč, včeš, ješ, ješ, ješ, ješ, ješ, ješ, ješ, ješ, ješ, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, to the old age of the song Piszkot or the first song of the day of the year of the 16th century Parking the song of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the soul of the Exactly, I'm afraid I've been here three years and I can pick out one or two words. I had Palkalney, I had the demons mentioned. But yeah, a little bit more serious, maybe. So let's hear that, Maraz. Good day, my friend. At home, I was in the middle of the river. I was in the middle of the river. I was in the middle of the river. I was in the middle of the river.
如果我们有足够的时间来做这件事。你知道，生活节奏如此之快，以至于我们有时会忘记我们拥有什么，以及有多少东西需要去包装。说真的，我在这里待了三年，只能勉强听懂一两个词。我听到了帕尔卡尼（Palkalney），听到了德迪·马拉兹（Dedek Mraz）被提及。但说真的，稍微严肃一点，让我们听听那个，马拉兹。你好，我的朋友。我在河中央，我在河中央，我在河中央，我在河中央。
I was in the middle of the river. I was in the middle of the river. Wow, he does that 900 times. I must be so nasty. I really, I like this guy. He's dedicated to his craft. That's fantastic. Did he mention that he had like a preference of which one he'd like to perform the most?
我在河中央。我在河中央。哇，他重复了900次。我一定很讨厌。我真的很喜欢这家伙。他致力于自己的技艺。这太棒了。他有没有提到他最喜欢表演哪一个？
He is a big fan of deadigmas. Yeah. Yeah. I mean, they're all excellent, but like, there's like, you can, I mean, you mentioned that he spent $2,000 on the costume alone, that deadigmas is really like, that's a great one. It's a great one, and it's, you know, it's the Slovenian icon, isn't it? And I think he really embodies it. But after the first year of data gathering
他是德迪·马拉兹的忠实粉丝。是的。我的意思是，它们都很棒，但你提到他光是服装就花了2000美元，德迪·马拉兹真的很棒，那是一个很棒的角色。而且，你知道，这是斯洛文尼亚的标志，不是吗？我认为他真的体现了这一点。但在第一年的数据收集之后，
from the Christmas 2020, he actually has this very unique data set of who is Slovenia's favorite digital center. Oh, because people order these custom videos. And so therefore he knows how many people want Santa versus Maclash versus dead Marass. Oh, this is fascinating. Okay, so what was the result? The 80% ordered Santa Claus video, 15% was Dedic Marass, and only 5% was McLeod. Wow, I mean, Santa Claus is great. You'll never get me distant Santa Claus,
从2020年圣诞节开始，他实际上拥有了一份非常独特的数据集，记录了谁是斯洛文尼亚人最喜欢的数字中心。哦，因为人们会订购这些定制视频。因此，他知道有多少人想要圣诞老人，多少人想要米克拉夫（Miklavž），多少人想要德迪·马拉兹。哦，这太迷人了。好的，那么结果是什么？80%的人订购了圣诞老人视频，15%是德迪·马拉兹，只有5%是米克拉夫。哇，我的意思是，圣诞老人很棒。你永远不会让我远离圣诞老人，
but I have to admit, I'm a little disappointed that Dech Merass isn't like really the most favorite in Slovenia, just because, you know, it's unique to Slovenia, that's what makes it so special. Yeah, you kind of want Dech Merass to be number one, don't you? But you do. But the way I see it is that Santa Claus has got everything, you know, as Greco says, you know, he's got the TV, he's got the songs, most of the songs, he's got the merch, he's got the advertising, you know, he's the king of the screen. And Slovenia, like any country is as outward facing as it is inward. So I think to have 20% of Slovenian parents choosing on turns, he was actually pretty incredible.
但我必须承认，我对德迪·马拉兹不是斯洛文尼亚最受欢迎的角色感到有点失望，因为你知道，这是斯洛文尼亚独有的，这才是它如此特别的原因。是的，你确实希望德迪·马拉兹排在第一位，不是吗？但你确实希望如此。但在我看来，圣诞老人拥有一切，正如格雷科所说，他有电视节目，有歌曲，大部分歌曲，他有周边商品，有广告，你知道，他是屏幕之王。而斯洛文尼亚，像任何国家一样，既面向外部也面向内部。所以我认为有20%的斯洛文尼亚父母选择德迪·马拉兹，这实际上相当了不起。
Yeah, yeah, that's a good point. That's a good point. Well, I'm totally fascinated by these three centers and how much they mean to the country and how much they sort of map onto the history of Slovenia. I just can't thank you enough for bringing the story to us. I just had a joy watching you make it and bring it to us. It's been fascinating. Thank you, Roman. It's been a pleasure. It's been fascinating. Thank you Roman, it's been a pleasure. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week By Will Aspenaw edited by Emmett Fitzgerald and Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Jim Briggs, fact checking by Graham Haysha, music by a director of Sound, Swan Rihau.
是的，是的，这是一个很好的观点。这是一个很好的观点。好吧，我完全被这三位圣诞老人迷住了，以及他们对这个国家意味着什么，以及他们如何在某种程度上映射出斯洛文尼亚的历史。我非常感谢你把这个故事带给我们。看着你制作并把它带给我们是一种乐趣。这太迷人了。谢谢你，罗曼。这是一种荣幸。这太迷人了。谢谢你，罗曼，这是一种荣幸。《99%无形》（99% Invisible）本周由威尔·阿斯彭诺（Will Aspenaw）制作，埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑，吉姆·布里格斯（Jim Briggs）进行混音和技术制作，格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）进行事实核查，音乐由声音总监斯旺·里豪（Swan Rihau）提供。
To Lingihong is the executive producer, Kurt Colxton is the digital director. The resident is Vivian Le, Lashemadon, Christopher Johnson, Chris Baroupe, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. Special thanks this week to Robert Kuznick. We are part of a Stitcher and Serious Exam podcast family.
图·林吉洪（To Lingihong）是执行制片人，库尔特·科尔克斯顿（Kurt Colxton）是数字总监。常驻人员包括薇薇安·勒（Vivian Le）、拉舍马顿（Lashemadon）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、克里斯·巴鲁普（Chris Baroupe）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。本周特别感谢罗伯特·库兹尼克（Robert Kuznick）。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员。
Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Well, on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love,
现在总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦（Pandora building）。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。当然，Instagram和Reddit上也可以。你可以找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目的链接，
as well as photos of Dedic Marass in action in Slovenia at our website. It's 9ibi.org. For all those who celebrate, I wish you a Merry Stitchmas and a seriously exam new year. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及德迪·马拉兹在斯洛文尼亚活动的图片，请访问我们的网站。网址是99pi.org。对于所有庆祝节日的人，我祝你们圣诞快乐，新年快乐。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。